right
for
okay ladies and gentlemen good evening
um welcome to this uh meeting of
internal over overview and scrutiny uh
committee meeting um and we will go
straight into the agenda uh
can I start by reminding people please
to switch on their microphone whenever
they speak the previous meeting we had
people watching on uh YouTube very very
difficult to hear people speak so please
speak loudly anyhow and also make sure
that your microphone is on um let's
start Kirsty apologies for absence no
apologies chair um move moving to the
minutes of the last
meeting
um when I
can get that
um so um going through page numbers um
looking for accuracy please first and
then any comment at the end page
three page
four page
five page
six page
seven
page8 page
nine can I have somebody to move those
as a true record counselor inch second
that please is councelor
Elliot moving now to the do we need to
vote on that sorry uh all those in
favor
and
abstentions for one and therefore there
isn't anything left to vote against good
uh moving to the action
list uh the first item on it um which
rests with me which is all to do with
Harbor board bford key and indeed um
flowing into the estri strategy we've
agreed to leave that because it's picked
up on the
last Point anyhow uh in a minute so
we'll comment that in a minute um next
Point
286 ascertain exact empty home figures
from other local
authorities and you can see there the um
response from Phil
Gilbert
um and
um
it
is a a a a fairly crude set of figures
those because it doesn't give you an
indication as to how many properties
there are in each um District anyhow and
therefore um some districts uh have or
authorities have a larger number but
they may have a larger number of
properties overall anyway so um in terms
of it's difficult to gauge percent es
but um there we see
um
um the figures there any comment on that
this
state
um moving on to point 287 which was to
circulate the planning enforcement
report which was given to us uh to town
and Parish councils and that has been
done uh by Democratic Serv services and
then
lastly uh the update on the EST
strategy um which is buil to come to us
in our April meeting and Shan Kerney has
confirmed that uh Chris Fuller will
attend and I propose to to widen that um
audience slightly so that actually in
that we cover
estery Harbor Key everything cuz it's
all
interconnected um and trying to deal
with it in Standalone stovepipe little
separate bits is no way forward if we
are looking at what is needed in the
future rather than just pedaling on with
the status quo um so um I propose to try
to widen that a bit um so that we can
look at it as a whole rather than um
everything
else any other comment on the action
list
good um public
contributions nothing no contributions
chair no um moving to Declarations of
interest uh counselors I remind you as
always um that um
it is your responsibility to uh inform
uh me um if you have an interest not
necessarily a conflict of interest but
an interest and that you declare that
item before the item is
discussed um I have no urgent matters
brought forward
um Ste no okay and we have uh no uh part
two so we can move straight on from that
so to the main item uh at this evening's
meeting which is the
um budget
2425 and the medium-term financial
strategy uh from 24 out to
29 um and for that
we um move to the section1 officer
Gordon all yours
thank you chair so item eight on the
agenda gives the committee the
opportunity to scrutinize the revenue
budget for next year before it goes to
full
Council so it doesn't include Capital
that's on a later paper and it covers
next year and the later next four years
which are indicative it covers the
funding position for the council so that
will look at council tax business rates
and funding from central government and
from council tax it also looks at the
overall robustness of the level of
Reserve
um while looking at the future deficits
um for the council in in beeting the
mismatch between income and
expenditure it also looks at the
adequacy of the main assumptions in the
budget such as regards pay and inflation
and funding and it looks at some of
those key risks and SE and sensitivities
to the overall budgetary
situation it ends by looking ahead and
seeing how we'll meet some of the Gap in
the in the budget that exists and if I
can just bring the um the committee
aware that at the moment there are still
some possible changes to these numbers
for uh for the the late settlement that
was received and it's still going to be
voted on tomorrow but also for changes
to the methodology for business
rates so when we set the budget this
time last year we anticipated ending
2223 with about 1.4 million in the
budgetary stabilization Reserve so this
is the the key Reserve by which we plan
to meet future deficits or mismatches in
funding however this was based upon
certain assumptions it assumed that we
would have an overspend in 2223 which
would have to be met from this reserve
and there was also certain assumptions
such as regarding treasury management um
staff pay and
inflation the budget at this time had a
structural deficit I.E an average
deficit divided by the average funding
level of around 1 a
half% so if we move on to the next
slide as it turned out things have
worked out differently so when we closed
the financial year
2223 there was actually an underspend
rather than overspend so we didn't take
from the budgetary stabilization Reserve
as had been anticipated so we start the
year 23 24 with around 2 million rather
than around 1.4 million
ion it's also the case that there are
some other differences to the
assumptions as has worked out in the
real world so for example we budgeted on
staff pay at 5% in actual fact it's
coming out at an average of near to
6.7% and also there's much higher income
from um from our cash balances so from
treasury management than we than we
budgeted for so in a sense you could say
that the uh there's some good one-offs
as regards treasury management um but of
course ongoing costs will be higher such
due to um inflation being built in
because treasury management goes up and
down but once inflation comes along the
cost generally stays at that
level the graph um on this slide is just
an illustration of some significant
changes that have taken place in some of
our
costs those of you that have been
counselors for a few years will be very
aware of the increas in costs in
temporary accommodation over the course
of 2122 and 22 23 well now if you look
at the anticip at outturn for 23 24
that's a that's now a reduction of
around 300,000 and that's possible
because of the increase in capacity um
that's taken place within um for the for
the for the private um private homes and
for the Hostile investment that's taken
place so that's the update now moving on
so so that's where the starting position
is different from where we anticipated a
year ago so now slide four just as a
reminder to all of you of the main
sources of fund
um for for the council so you can see
that fees and charges is the single
largest area then business rates but it
also shows the importance of council tax
and the 4.8 million um that we get from
there and of course central government
funding which is the smaller slice
that's got significantly smaller over
the last few
years so in carrying on talking about
our funding position for next year so
we' so we've talked about the overall
funding position now this is talks about
this next slide talks about some of the
funding from Central governments well so
that it's much much better for financial
planning if we can get um information
over two three or four years from
central government but unfortunately um
it was just only onee settlement again
which doesn't aid financial planning a
great
deal we know for us that there's around
a 2% increase in Grants from Central
governments
in terms of how governments have
communicated the changes in the
settlement um across all funding streams
and with assumed increases in council
tax base and business rates there's a
guarantee that all district councils
should have their total funding
increased by
4.9% and income from business rates will
be going up by the rate of inflation and
there's an increase of 1.1% on our
business rate tax base and there's also
further reliefs still in place for
leisure retail and
[Applause]
Hospitality so moving on to council tax
this is just a reminder to all of you
that of the total amount of council tax
that torage collects a very small
proportion actually is related to torage
council itself so our numbers are are
relatively insignificant and almost
three quarters relates to um is come
from Devon County
Council so the report also describes the
process by which council tax is
calculated um and the way it in which is
it set so it talks about the tax base
agreed by Council back in December and
it also is just a reminder that the
maximum that District councils can raise
council tax by before a rendum is a
referendum is called is 2.99% and that's
part of the recommendation to you
today and it's just a reminder that the
proportion so as well as the proportion
of funding from central government
falling the proportion of council tax
that relates to torage is also falling
over recent years as the County Council
and the police and the fire have been
able to raise council tax by a higher
level than the than the district
council the next slide just shows in
very
practical terms to the man on the street
or the woman on the street what the
recommended increase relates to for um
on a weekly
basis so councilors will be aware that
council tax bands are in those eight
different categories a to H um and for
purposes of calculation there's an
assumed level of band D in the middle so
if we do so the recommendation is to go
from £184 to9 8950 which is a550
increase and that of course doesn't
assume any reduction from council tax
support
[Applause]
so we've looked at funding now this next
slide brings together the the income and
the expenditure for the council for the
next five years so there's a few key
things to note here so you've got the
graph showing the the income and the
expenditure and also you've got the
table at the bottom which shows the
deficit per
year so obviously the first thing to
note is that there's a Gap in every
single year starting at half a million
and going up to um over
900,000 the Gap is
increasing and so you as last year we
had a structural deficit of 1 and a
half% now we're looking at a structural
deficit of nearer to
6% and the the very simple explanation
for this is inflation so we've had
situations where our funding has gone up
by by perhaps 2% perhaps
2.99% or perhaps by inflation
um but of course our costs have G up by
significantly more than that we've
talked about staff pay but also over the
last few years you can imagine what's
happened to utility bills and to fuel
and those sort of things as well so
funding's simply not kept up with
expenditure so the next
slide this shows in graphical terms what
this means to our level of reserves so
even though we have approximately 13
million pound worth of IM AR reserves
there's three M there's there's 2
million set aside to meet um future
deficits so and this graph if we'd have
shown the same grass graph last year it
would have shown a lower starting point
at 1.4 million but it didn't show that
Reserve being drained over the whole
period of the mtfs so this is how one
year has changed so now we're in a
situation where after three years all of
the budget set aside to meet deficits
will have been will will will have run
out other things being
equal
so it's it's important
that I show to councilors all the main
assumptions within it because of course
it's only by looking at the assumptions
that you can assess the robustness of
the of the budget while we're assuming
that council tax goes up by the maximum
that we can over the life of the mtfs
without calling for a referendum we're
assuming that central government support
continues at the same level but doesn't
actually increase so that's quite a
prudent assumption there we're showing
um continuation of business rate still
going up by
inflation I'm we're assuming inflation
is two and a half percent we also
mentioned staff pay um which could now
look like it could be higher than
inflation and of course there are also
significant assumptions as regards
treasury management because that's
something that is going to make a a real
difference to our to our position over
the next couple of years so we're
assuming 4% with base rates currently at
5.25 but that figure will go down as we
draw down on reserves to meet spend in
the capital
program we're also assuming further
increases in other traded services such
as for car parking um and also some
further reductions for temporary
accommodation as the as the investment
in capacity which is in the capital
program is
implemented
so there's a whole Realms of risks and
sensitivities within the budget and
these of course can throw out the future
Year's um numbers quite
significantly and obviously these the
key risks and sensitivities are going to
involve interest rates funding from
central government and um interest rates
and things like this so in the in the
report it gives you a description of a
few of these and how it can can change
the the final deficit situation um so
for example there could be reviews of
central government funding that are
often that are often talked about so the
fairer funding review or a reset of Base
rates but the graph in front of you
shows the illustration of what will
happen to the deficit um if council tax
isn't raised for just one year so and
obviously because you can't once you've
not used the maximum in any one year you
can't catch up in future years so it's
it's it's an annual allowance if you
like um so this makes a difference of
236,000 less funds that the council have
available each and every year even if we
still increase council tax in future
years and obviously on a cumulative
basis that's another million pounds of
deficit so there's a lot of it may
appear that there's a lot of Doom and
Gloom in the report but actually the
council does have a really good record
in delivering safe savings the member
budget working group has worked very
successfully in recent years to deliver
savings options and they'll soon reset
again to to to look further into that um
but we know of course the headline
numbers do show a significant take from
the stabilization Reserve next year and
over the next few years so the position
clearly isn't sustainable but it's also
the case as well this report just looks
at Revenue but of course much of the
spend of the council will be
characterized um more by Capital spend
than by Revenue spend when you think
about some of the transformative and
exciting projects that are that are out
there but of course Revenue budget we're
effectively going to be running to stand
still it's going to be an effort to
continue services at the current
level and the next slide just
illustrates how things might another
illustration of how things might not be
quite as bad as it seems so for example
we budget for large volatile income
streams such as planning or car parking
based upon what we're confident we will
bring in but in reality of course you
could bring in significantly more
especially with regards to things like
planning income we have relatively
prudent assumptions but the planning
income could be four
500,000 pounds more um in reality
doesn't appear likely because things
seem to be slowing down but it is a
volatile area and we budget based upon
what we what we're pretty confident
we're going to get in some of those
other changes um there could be reduced
support for active torage um um there
could be increases to capacity for car
parking which get mentioned and lots of
other ideas which are which are
currently circulating so and these are
just the ones that are to hand available
without changing um service provision so
there's lots of opportunities out
there so thank you chair the last slide
just Rec um reminds full Council of what
the recommendations are um in the report
and that's over the increase to council
tax the net revenue budget the
contribution to reserves um and to
restate the work of the members budget
working group in bringing resources back
into balance um for years 25 26 and OMS
thank you
chair Gordon thank you for that um
before we um consider the
recommendations um we'll first of all go
into a general discussion I I I've got a
question but I'm going I'm going to
leave it for a while first of all
anybody got um questions that they want
to ask of of Gordon um um or comment
that they want to make on what they've
seen Mr council tax I noticed that 67%
of our council tax is gained by people
from a b and
c is this in line with other
councils
we we know we have a quite a different
housing mix to other to other District
councils we have much more um in in
those in those lower value
hes so therefore does the government
actually reflect this because I looked
at the sparcity fund and all the rest of
it we seem to be losing more and more
being Rural and having these lower
costs is that going to be
met well there there's a a very
complicated four block model which
government government used to determine
it and there is elements in there for
relative resource and for rurality and
sparcity and these kind of elements
obviously where we have the opportunity
to feed into the reworkings of this
model we do make sure we emphasize those
those features that are that are unique
to
us uh
yeah Steve come back on it yeah excuse
me Ju Just to to add to that there's
been a um I sure you way a long running
debate about how council tax in Rural
and District areas um is far higher than
some of our Urban counterparts so
council tax in many districts is
higher uh respectively the some London
Authority so there is a a disparity in
in the system and you know rate r value
the values used as we all stem back to
the early '90s so it's just it's it's a
system which has and has argued many
flaws in it in terms of
funding councelor
Lovel um it was very pleasing to see
that the um temporary accommodation
costs are anticipated coming down as a
result of Sully house and all the
business or whatever's been going can I
ask and and that's a prediction is that
a prediction on
the numbers continuing to come down is
there like because I I get a feeling you
know from press and what have you
that temp the need for housing temporary
housing is going
up and our capacity for coping with it
is also going up so overall hopefully
it's coming do you see you see what I'm
trying to ask so is
that is that overly optimistic or is
that of the
precious do you see what I'm trying to
ask yeah absolutely well this only takes
you to The Current financial year so
we've got really good information for
the current Financial year so so for the
most part what we're not seeing is an
increase in the number of people that
we're responsible for housing and we
don't and I'm not assuming as part of
this budget that we're assuming an
increase in the number of people um that
we'll be responsible for housing but of
course that's a consequence of two
things anyway it's not just aggregate
demand it's also the houses social
housing for people to move into
afterwards those those are the key
points so and what we've seen over the
course of this year is is a is a
stabilization of the numbers after
having seen very large increases in
previous years that's great to hear
yeah thank you chair um just a question
really on the stabilization reserve and
and perhaps how it works so we've got
we're starting the year with 2 million
at the moment and by 26 27 we hit that
uncomfortable crossing the threshold
what does that actually look like for
the running and the managing of the
district council what are the
constraints that that begins to put on
us what it means in reality well we
don't but we're not planning for the
time when we get there we're planning to
avoid getting to that point when the
result Reserve Runs Out in reality so
it's about taking action um before then
to get to the point where it runs out
because of course we're always going to
need some res reserves available to meet
the Vol the natural inherent volatility
and risks um that exists so in reality
it's not about what happens when we get
there because we very much planned that
we won't be there it's about making
managerial action and sort of policy and
prioritization type decisions so that
before we get there um we've we've we've
managed our our our spend
down so from that point of view
what does that look like and in terms of
what we need to do what we can do
between now and then because that gives
us two years and and what is our minimum
threshold so if we suddenly found we
were at say half a million rather than
two million you know do the flags go
from one color to another or do we just
say okay we're still all right we've
still got Road I mean what Point does
the pinch Point come and how soon do we
need to address it before we can stop
that I I'll just remind the committee
that when the members budget working
group SATs 12 months ago it delivered
around £700,000 worth of savings so
there are opportunities out there but of
course it gets harder and harder as you
go through the process to find savings
so it will be harder for 25 26 than it
was for 23 24 um but but yeah in reality
of course it's it starts off by looking
at external grants and by looking at Fe
and
charges and the like and it and it and
it moves on to a broader range of areas
that you're that are less
favorable so just picking up on that
that as you say the budget working group
in a sense probably got the low hanging
fruit and maybe have done a bit of
higher pruning but it gets difficult now
doesn't it so I'm guessing they're going
to have to start looking at some of
those strategies within their workflow
yeah it gets increasingly difficult and
and increasingly um problematic without
a doubt and and it's and it would become
more more of a public decision
um but yeah but we've got I mean there
are there are ideas out there there are
option there are options out there you
know we're we've still got a long way to
go before we're anywhere near some of
the scare stories here nationally thank
you um I'm just going to bring Steve in
on that one because he was wanting to
yeah it just to to add to that obviously
be it'd be wrong to start talking in
detail of any changes that uh might be
proposed at this stage obviously
Gordon's outlined a couple of things in
the in the report obviously one of the
critical factors which was highlighted
was the movement in temporary housing
temporary accommodation cost from Circ
two two to 300,000 up to a million and
that's something that's being
experienced across a range of
authorities how and authorities and
those responsible for temporary
combination obviously the government
have made some changes to the local
housing
allowance uh we along with other
authorities through the LJ are lobbying
for changes on the housing benefit
subsidy cap which has been frozen since
2011 so that's been so what that means
is we're only able to claim so much of
the money we spend on temp temp
accommodation back through the subsidy
system them and that's been frozen and
rents have obviously gone up
significantly so I think the the purpose
of that Reserve is to allow members the
time and capacity to take a measured
approach of decisions needed to build
that uh or bridge that Gap over the
coming years and obviously the intention
is that will start now um but that level
of Reserve gives that level of
opportunity to think rather than making
any knee-jerk reactions uh because
things change um periodically anyway as
gon mentioned planning income goes up
and down car parking income goes up and
down it'd be wrong to say we're going to
make fundamental changes now and then
regret it later because some of those
assumptions have changed so that's the
purpose of having that Reserve to take a
more ma measured
approach thank you councelor
Loval sorry uh just a question on um
staff costs um obviously you know
inflation and pay agreements and all
things going up whatever but I
understand and maybe I'm out of date but
there are quite a few vacancies on the
you know jobs that important jobs that
have been advertised which haven't been
filled and and are temporarily hopefully
being filled by agency staff I mean I
might be saying things wrong um and I
just wondered how is is that sort of
like built into to the numbers or is
that 5 point whatever just pay increases
do you see what I mean are you is that
built in as well I mean hopefully it's
not going to be a continuing situation
and um permanent staff will be
attractive to come and work in our
beautiful in terms of the budget it it's
the the the the staff increase in
Staffing in the budget is essentially to
do with the staff pay award that we've
seen in terms of some of the in-year
pressures that is essentially to do with
the number of vacancies and the amount
of um agency cost that we've had to pay
to bring in um especially professional
staff but you know staff across the
board so hopefully hopefully that
explains
it so that's included in in that yes so
so in so for so for next year there is
some um budget for agency costs um but
but of course there is um a builtin
assumption that we won't experience the
same level um of of vacancies that we do
currently uh councelor
craigy yeah I just wanted to ask on um
your sort of assumptions around the
increase that we've had of energy prices
during the more and obviously you talk
about external funding one of the
council's commitment is obviously to
decarbonize and reduce that overall
amount of energy do you see that there's
a good prospect that we can reduce the
amount of energy expenditure on
that well certainly where we invest in
new buildings and new assets it's
absolutely there would be an assumed
lower level of energy use in our new
buildings was than there was in our in
our old ones so I think we set a very
high standard where we're making
Investments um aside from
that it's the the budget to to give a
straight answer the budget is more based
upon what we think the cost is going to
be next year but we very much hope that
as we go down the route to
decarbonization energy costs do
fall um if I can just return to the area
that
uh um Mr denate um raised and that is
the the deficit over the five-year
period And if I can take the advantage
of um two members of the um member
budgetary working group who are with us
our own councelor Hodson I think hson
not on are you're not on it now anymore
right no I've been demoted and it's
Hodson but sorry and at least we have
the leader here anyway he you're on it
aren't
you don't don't worry I you can you can
answer my question in a minute the as
the chief executive has eloquently
pointed out we can you do not allow the
reserve to come down to the zero zero
level it doesn't hit the ground because
if you do you lose all your flexibility
so the Reserve at the moment is Circa
roughly 2 million P um and this is what
we used to call a transition Reserve
isn't it now we call the budgetary
stabilization reserve it sounds a bit
more
um therefore war and we hit at the
moment on the current projection as we
saw we hit ground level in 2 years time
and in a further two years time by the
time we get to the end of the midterm
Financial strategy period uh we are it's
2 million below so therefore simple math
tells us that in order to keep the
Reserve at a level line and stop it
going down we're looking for about2
million pounds worth of savings now is
the member budgetary working group
um are you setting yourself that type of
Target because so far I would suggest
although very um you you you've you've
answered the the questions posed to you
by being able to slightly Tink around
the edges take the the easy bits as we
talked about of course you do the the
lwh hanging fruit as some people would
call it
this is in a different order and in
order to actually get that line to go
horizontal and bring it away from the
downward Trend there are going to have
to be some nasty decisions taken are the
budgetary working group actually focused
on on looking for those type of savings
and making those type of
recommendations first of all I've got no
real answer
but when we started last time we we sort
of decided we wouldn't go below a
million so we looked at the cuts we
needed to do to keep that at that level
we've been fortunate in so muches there
has been additional government money um
we've recently had uh 1% increase in the
rural um funding I think it's 1% also uh
I don't know what we put in the budget
um Gordon but last week in the last two
days we've had this week in the last
couple of days we've had the new homes
bonus confirmed which I think is pretty
much what we were expecting it wasn't
any more and it wasn't any less um it's
going to get
harder but if you look at what's going
on in general and and obviously we get
all the financial stuff from the
government I think there's a recognition
now that the situation can't be allowed
to get worse
um we're in a reasonable position as a
council uh the publish deficit of 400
I'm hoping is going to have with the
additional money um and I'm optimistic
but that's a hope rather than and that
will still keep us as one of the lowest
councils in Devon with a deficit there
is some Financial stuff which I don't
altogether understand as how we're doing
all our big projects and how the money
is circulating what we're having to use
of our own money in order to do that so
it it may come down a bit but it may
come up when the money comes in we
haven't had a group meeting yet rather
than to sign off this budget but
obviously it's going to be really tough
to find you know that it's always saying
the lwh hanging fruit is always the
easiest but I think there is a
realization in government that it can't
go on if you look at the number of
councils are in serious financial
trouble um they are are going to have to
be more realistic but having said that
is quite hard work I I and several of
the other leaders in Devon wrote to the
uh leveling up minister or Dak saying
that we can't carry on like this and
that's when we got the 1% which is
really a little bit of fluff around the
edges rather than a really serious
resolve
but I'm optimistic we can still probably
float around the million rather than um
certainly when we started with David
Hayes the intention was not to go below
a million and whilst we slipped towards
it various government funds have kept us
back up to two and we've got to work on
that basis I think the projection is
right if things don't improve we will
end up there but so will most of the
other councils in the country country
and so um it's done to us to look at
we've got to be realistic we can't give
money away no matter what pet projects
we all have as individuals we can't
can't accommodate it um in the off
chance that we don't get any more money
and then we are in trouble um but I'm
hoping I think we we were thinking of
having one this week but we got
something else on this week so we will
shortly we're hoping to start the Budget
Group again in March I think Gordon I'm
not sure all the day and then we will
start looking realistically at where we
are where we're going to be and what
action we will need to take and
hopefully building some topup money when
the government realizes that we're all
under pressure but the fact is we've got
the largest national debt we've ever had
um it is costing us a ridiculous amount
of money and at some point like every
household you've got to rain it in um so
so yeah I hope that that's a long-winded
answer of saying I'm hoping we can keep
what we set out to do which was to stay
above a million in the reserves and that
has to be the Hope thank you for that
and I apologize for putting you on the
spot unbathed um I'm just going to ask
actually Steve to to to to embellish
that slightly for a moment uh and then
I'll come back to you CL I I wasn't
excuse me chair I wasn't going to change
anything obviously the reason the budget
working group haven't got a Target yet
is is because full Council hasn't set
the budget yet so it'd be difficult to
set the target until the budget set um
on the 19th of February otherwise it
could be it could be moving again I
think one of the and one of the reasons
I pointed out the temporary
accommodation costs are because that's
gone up uh by such a significant level
if that hadn't gone up that's by far our
greatest pressure and that's one of the
reasons why we've been trying to tackle
that not because it's just a an
increased cost um it's also a massive
budget pressure and as I said there's
been lots and lots of lobbying now I
don't expect that's going to be solded
in the short term um and not suggesting
we're going to be able to solve such a
big housing crisis but it's something an
area we need to continue to focus our
attention on as well as many other areas
because when you when Gordon started the
presentation
you kind of saw the movements between
one year and between last year and this
year and that happens on quite a regular
basis um that's why I was saying you you
know we wouldn't want to set real hard
target I'm not going to say it's going
to be easy and make significant changes
in one F swoop then to think oh if ID
known that was going to change or that
was going to move that way I wouldn't
have cut this service or Cho this off
that's why we've got we're in a an an
enviable position compared to other
authorities we've got the time uh to
make those decisions on a on a rational
measured basis and that's why if we wait
we'll hopefully get the bud we'll get
the budget set on the 19th uh as the
leader mentioned I think there's a
budget working group set up um very
shortly after that and then that will
set the the direction for that group
over the coming months and through this
year thank you Steve councelor Hudson
thank you I perhaps ought to put it
right that I I wasn't demoted I was
uh I I switched um my roles and
responsibilities to that of homelessness
when we had a new Administration coming
in and housing um because the previous
incumbent hadn't been reelected and we
needed someone um to take the the lead
on that I think one of the things that
we haven't discussed here today we try
we know we're in an election year we do
there are so many unknown quantities
about what is going to happen within the
next 12 months so is quite
speculative um we have to make some
assumptions admittedly but we don't know
what's ahead for us um that's my first
point the second point I think with the
introduction of second home council tax
that may well impact on our housing
market we may see landlords coming or
going back into um the private sector
rental market because we have seen an
incredible in when the uh figures have
been
escalating um for our housing costs uh a
lot of it is attributable to the
shrinkage in the price private rented
sector and the increasing rents which
again I think somebody touched on about
the increase in their local housing
allowance that we are strongly lobbying
for because it is so out of date it's
nowhere near what we're having to pay
for rentals so I think there's some
things that are being in the pipeline in
progress that may well assist us with
meeting this deficit just on that front
so I'm not
too I'm always The Optimist I'm not too
despondent in this because as we say the
biggest cost to our budget has been our
temporary accommodation and we are
striving hard with the other districts
across the county and indeed nationally
to address these issues so it is going
to be a hot topic for any
election so um I remain positive and
even though I might not be on the budget
working group I have the ear of somebody
who is so I've B that frequently thank
you thank you for that um it'll be
interesting in this election year I'd be
very surprised if if any government
irrespective of what fla color it is or
flavor it is I'd be I'd be surprised if
anybody's got going to have more cash to
be able to Splash about um so I think
we're very wise to continue one thing I
picked up from
that is that and as the the the leader
uh pointed out the
um the budget working group have made an
assumption
that and previous section 151 officer
had a similar assumption that a million
pounds was about where the flaw of the
the of or or the reserve that should be
maintained in the transition stroke the
budgetary stabilization
Reserve I think that that level of
Reserve is actually a key element in
terms of how we how seriously we take
the the line as it heads down and the
emphasis which is put onto the working
group I would have thought that actually
the level of Reserve should be something
that should be directed by full
Council um and therefore then that gives
direction to the budgetary working group
uh to say you have to work to and it's
not their assumption it's full council's
assumption that that is we want to
maintain a reserve of at least
million um for for the
unforeseen is that um a reasonable
assumption or
not yeah uh chair I guess this is one
other thing we've got to remember in
addition to that reserve the council
holds a general Reserve which I think is
just over a million
pound and I guess one of the one of the
things we have to be cautious to is um
the fact that hold in high level
reserves isn't exactly flavor of the
month and and I you know there are there
are political angles to that so we're
not going to get into that debate but
it's it's about having sufficient to
manage the ups and downs of uh any will
changes in Pay inflation and charge and
all of that so and I'm not suggesting po
Council shouldn't uh indicate the figure
but we've just got to be mind for and
that and that Steve is fine as long as
your budget predection is flat is on a
horizontal ours is not ours is doing
that at the moment um and so it you know
it doesn't I I accept that we are not
here to be a bank we're not trying to
hold taxpayer money more than we need to
of course we don't but we in order to be
responsible we must actually have that
headr room just as you would do in your
own bookkeeping or household keeping as
well so I just think that there is a
level of accountability in the amount of
unallocated Reserve we have and whether
that is a higher level Reserve or
whether it is this Reserve I think just
we we we need to have
a an agreement um with full Council as
to where we want to be what that buffer
should be Gordon you want to come in
yeah I was going to say it is it is
something that other councils do have
which is a reserves policy which
actually brings together a lot of these
ideas and actually sets parameters um of
where the council wants to be in the in
the short medium and long term
so that and that is how you would you
you would as um your experience of of of
best practice that's that's how you
would exp you you would describe the
best way of doing it would be a reserves
policy
well well that's something that other
councils do do and that's something that
we can we can consider taking on board
just just to sort of um crystallize in a
sense how we want our reserves to be
operated Mr
Den thank you for that I I think that's
where I was going in terms of the
methodology to calculate the reserves
policy so there'll be a formula behind
how you get to that figure I think the
other thing is no you don't want to hold
High Reserves I recognize that but that
there is an element of good stewardship
in knowing that you've got enough that
gives you the comfortable level of room
for maneuver including the old
occasional Financial shock when
something big comes in so a good
methodology over a period of different
Financial years I think could give the
council confidence in setting that level
so that that's one thing I think it
would be worth us exploring the other
thing I just wanted to pick up on if I
may just on a comment that was made I
think it would be really good to get
confidence
around some of the capital projects
whether they're going to be forward
funded or whether they're going to be
send the bills in and we're pay you in
six months in a re because that also
would impact Upon Our liquidity and the
need for reserves so I mean having a
clear understanding of how that might
work at some point would be
good
yes come on come on yes can yeah I'm
happy with the principle I would be
concerned about a figure because at the
moment the government's policy is we
have to use our
reserves rather silly policy but that's
only our view um so the the issue would
be if a full Council sets a million and
we drop to 900,000 what do we do so I
think
Gordon's um approach of we have a policy
of retaining a reserve that is I don't
know you word it whether it's sensible
to our current balance or something and
I'm happy with that because informally
that's what we did the danger is is the
two two dangers one is the government is
convinced that we're all set on millions
and keeps telling us to spend them and
we know that's not happening and they
should know what that's not happening
because the sheer number of councils
balance in on a
114 and the other issue is we will as a
working group we're going to be tied to
that figure and I think we need that
flexibility a little bit to say we know
as a group we discussed that we want to
reserve policy and our aim would be to
end up with that million but that will
change during the year it may come a bit
under it may go over and our our
what we need to do is to keep our eye on
that figure and do what we think we need
to do to get to it so I'm happy with the
principle of retaining
Reserve I wouldn't put a figure on it
because the government will look at it
and say um because it's the same with
the council tax they say to us you can
increase the council tax by 2.9 and if
we went back and said no we're not going
to do that they say well you don't need
as much in reserves um from the central
government
budget so it's a no- win situation
that's what we've got to face as a
district council we're not going to win
what we have to do is to make the best
of it we can so I'm happy with the
principle we retain a we do our best to
retain a reserve and I'm happy within
the group to discuss that as a guide but
I would be very reluctant to tie the
working group and knowing government
policy at the moment to put a figure on
it councelor thank you councelor
craigy well I agree is very difficult to
put a a value uh and amount um on a
reserves policy I just wanted to raise
the fact that obviously inflation is
eroding the spending power of those
reserves all the time so even sticking
with the same figer means it's its
ability to provide the council with
Services is less um and just to say that
obviously in the charity sector we look
at how many months of expenditure those
reserves are going to last you so it's
relates to the expenditure rather than a
fixed sum of money um that's all I
wanted to
add piggy back on that and just say and
that's right and in a sense you don't
set necessarily A Hard figure you set a
range and you recognize the the cycle of
expend and income because not every
month is going to be a heavy month but
some would be more some would be less so
that's within the methodology so yes I
agree it's not a question of having the
figure and the floor it's a question of
knowing the parameters that you're
working and if you have the methodology
you can justify why you're holding that
level thanks chair um any quick couple
of comments obviously it's for your
section1 officer uh to recommend and
determine an adequate level of reserves
that's a specific uh
statement uh Gordon has to make and and
Mr denate Right what what you what we
tend to do is look at those areas of
high risk so temporary accommodation car
park fees planning income those things
that have a high level of volatility and
you can risk assess those income expend
expenditure streams to determine what's
an adequate level of reserves and as the
leader said those things move up and
down from year to year which is why you
have an annual budget setting process
and why then Accord to section 151
recommends a level of reserves and
whether or not they're adequate or not
and clearly our Auditors take their view
as well and report back to the audit and
governance committee so that there's
there's a a range of controls already in
place through kind of stat statutory
provision
um
I having heard that discussion and heard
the section1 officer H and the chief
executive my view is that the the policy
of
reserves which which which is a key
element um because once that res once
you've actually gone down it's much more
difficult to get back up again to create
that that safety buffer in which things
will bounce up and down but that's
because there's a buffer there not
because you've actually come so close to
the bottom that suddenly you go
below that a policy is uh sounds to me
um actually a a sensible and prudent
thing I hear uh the the the leader
comment about not wanting to bind the
working group's hands too
much having said that the working group
um should be given direction from for
Council um it is but a working group as
opposed to a committee with its own
statutary powers and and I think it is
it is sensible that there should be a
policy in place it doesn't have to be
enormous but um that there is a policy
in place to to cover that um
a as such I I would would would uh move
that there should be uh an additional um
or an amendment um to the
recommendations that are before us uh
which would
include a
recommendation that um this Council
um adopts a reserves policy uh or a
policy for the management of its
Reserves
um that can be put together in um slower
time and and can be scrutinized to to to
make sure that we have uh a policy
rather than
the I wouldn't say the whim but the the
the view of any one individual at a time
uh be it um uh be it officer or be it um
a a small small working group of members
councelor Hudson you're going to add WIS
wisdom to that as the former lead member
for finance and I haven't worked with
Gordon but I work very closely with
David
Hayes the responsibility of the1 Officer
is to guide this Authority with a
prudent budget and to give us the
assurance that the way we are
progressing um is appropriate now that's
backed up by a very experienced
previous1 officer and our chief
executive so for me because there is
regular reporting of our budgetary uh
provision to full Council and our 151
officer is responsible for informing us
of variations fluctuations
Etc I personally I'm happy
you say no one person ought to be
responsible that's why we have A1
officer that's why we have a requirement
to have one who holds that
responsibility now if we start trying to
say well yes you can advise us but we
still want a policy I think we're in
danger of undermining the authority of
the1 Officer now this is just my opinion
uh the chief exec might not agree age uh
Gordon himself might not agree but I am
confident that we have had really
Financial prudent management and I think
it is for us to listen and to challenge
and ask questions but not to set policy
in that
direction CH it might be useful just for
me to come back so um We're Not absent
of a policy everyone of the council's
reserves has a policy for its use the
only thing it sounds as though you're
indicating missing is an indicative
balance on this budget stabilization
Reserve that has has its policy in
itself it's only used for the that
purpose so the only thing it sounds as
though you're indicating missing is a
level by which you wouldn't want that
wouldn't necessarily want that to fall
below um the other thing I would stress
is they may be good reasons for it to
fall below that level if you're going to
start a project or initiative use money
from a reserve that generates future
savings uh then that would be a valid
reason for it going below that I think
that the final point and the the chair
of the audit and governance committee is
here this evening um those levels of
reserves are they reported in the
council's annual accounts and
uh as part of the governance framework
ordin governance are responsible for
ensuring that um Arena and that
framework for governance is adequate
adequate adequately uh monitored and
reported on so I said I think the only
thing you seem to be missing is a level
by which you wouldn't want that one uh
balance to fall
below yeah I was going to say that I'm
quite quite welcome to sort of second
that proposal of having that sort of
over overarching view of a uh reserves
policy because obviously each individual
Reserve has that policy but you need to
see things in the overview of how they
work together as well and there's no
reason why having set set a a policy you
can't amend it or change it as
circumstances allow but I think one of
the for for me one of the compelling
issues is it improves transparency and I
think the aim of any sort of uh
government uh body should be to try and
be as transparent as it is possible to
be so so I I
would I I um I don't share um councelor
hodson's um uh caution um I I recognize
and accept uh her experience in in this
area and also her experience in the the
area of local government um but uh even
so I think th this is uh I mean we we
just heard with the meeting started in a
way with with with the leader saying
that the working group made an
assumption that you know it didn't want
to go below a certain amount we've seen
um forecasts given to us to tonight
which show that at at the moment with no
further action on current figures as we
can see them it actually uh runs very
quickly into a negative uh uh territory
um and I just think that there actually
should be a
um slightly um clearer uh and
more as you said more more transparent
statement as to how much generally we
think we should be have as a safety
buffer uh within the budget the chief
executive says it there will times it
will be dipped into if that is Justified
and explained people will be quite happy
to sign up to that but I think it's an
area that that that that that ought to
be um have
a a general policy set on it so I I I I
would actually um uh stick with that
recommendation that we should we should
add that as a um um to our
recommendations
um
counc cotan I don't really see the
benefit of it because count um Steve Hur
just said that we already do have a
policy for the reserves so I don't
really
understand the benefit of what we
haven't said and we what we don't say in
that ultimately
is
H the size of that Reserve be it in
percentage terms or or or or numerically
or whatever
or I I just find it's a it's a it
it's an area which is
undefined in terms of you
know we are we are hearing at the moment
of councils all over the country who've
allowed themselves to for one reason or
another and and for many out of their
control where actually their finances
have run down and they' they've run
below the line and it's suddenly become
a crisis and as was mentioned earlier we
actually are going to take action before
we get to the line but as a result where
is that line and who is saying what that
line is we have advice from the section
151 officer U But ultimately at the end
of the day the authority of the budg
budget is when the for Council actually
votes on it and approves it that is the
authority with which then the Gordon and
the team go forward and and and make it
work um obviously um with his advice but
the whole thing is constructed with
different policies and and AIMS in in in
in in in mind so
um sorry how I don't understand how it
would be more transparent as well
because we've already had it explained
that everything goes through the audit
and governance committee which is all in
public and I just don't really fully
understand why
ordin in my view everything is
transparent as it is because we hear now
this is on YouTube it's through our
section1 officer um but our our finances
should be um should be working Accord
according to to to policies which are
actually I think s of laid down as
opposed to just a picked up in meetings
on a on a
um are you wanting to come back
on my frustration with that you know we
employed A1 officer we've got a working
group and then you want full Council to
tie our hands to what has to be the
limit and through the year that will go
up and down I think it's slightly
disingenuous to bring in the fact that
on the last set of round we were looking
at not going below a million because we
were looking at the lwh hanging uh fruit
we knew worse things were come we knew
we had to keep money in hand but at the
end of the day it is government policy
at the moment that we use the reserves
and also once you start tying a
stone you know it it's just making more
work we are responsible to all of you
from the working group and from the1
officer to present you with transparent
open accounts that balance and it's
worked what we've done now you
suggesting you set limits that we work
to and if I recall we created the
working group to identify savings
because we had a a funding crisis that
is the purpose of the working group it
may have grown legs a bit as it's gone
on but the purpose of the working group
was to identify savings and report back
to full Council which is what we did
right so it's not a wider budget setting
organization councelor bright thank you
chair I just wanted to kind of
understand if we have a new policy
written how does it direct us on uh
where we need to make our savings or how
much savings we need to make is it not
already the information we're
seeing just I think what I just trying
to do is is is
it I was I was trying to ensure that
full Council have confidence that the
working group who are tasked with
fine-tuning the future budget to make it
actually stay on course in other words
fine savings um that they were aiming to
the right Target and somebody needs to
say what the target is and if we are
saying that the
budgetary stabilization Reserve in
general terms is not to fall below1
million that is the target but where has
that actually been
said CH
we sorry I think we mustn't over
complicate this I think the the thing
about a reserves policy it is just one
of a number of financial instruments
that you have but I often liken it to
the fuel gauge on a car
the faster you go the quicker the fuel
goes the slower you go less it goes and
it's one of those things that you know
if suddenly you find yourself on a
sleep sharp downward Trend which we seem
to be you know how to kind of manage
that level so it is an early warning
indicator it it is about transparency
but it's also about in a sense other
people being able to understand as well
and it's one of those one of those
Concepts that people find they can
manage to grasp so it's probably going
to be an indicator that people would
help it the council would be able to
explain how they manage their reserves
and how they manage the amount of income
that they're keeping for these sort of
things through that policy and that
that's really the point of policy but
the policy can be changed as been said
and the point about policy is it's there
for our benefit is not there as a
constraint and you don't fix a figure
you fix a range and you fix a
methodology to explain that range and
you adapt it and and you adapt it in the
light of
experience
yeah CH I guess if if you think of it
it's um somewhat more practically you've
already got in place your uh levers
tools mechanisms for measuring this so
you've got the budget that will be set
in February that budget is reported to
this committee on quarterly basis so you
get reports of whether um the council's
on track or off track so that's by far
your best method of measuring uh the
direction of travel of the council the
budget working group isn't drawing money
out of that out of that Reserve or
putting money in that Reserve that
Reserve is reported on an annual basis
to CNR as it was last week this
committee and full Council next year
next uh NE this month um in two weeks
time so it's not something that floats
up and down it's the actions that are
taken during the year um the scrutiny
you undertake of the budget on a
quarterly basis and the regular reports
that go to full
Council um of the work of the budget
that the outcome of the budget working
group so all of those things are already
in place yes as the leader said wouldn't
want that that figure to fall below that
that level ideally um because we want
that buffer but I I can't see there's
any need for a particular policy other
than um it say other than full Council
saying yes we'd like to stay within that
the range of that
figure but you've already got um such a
range of mechanisms for ensuring the
council's on track
already
you've got you've got lots of people
looking at it including ourselves but
actually what
um what Target or figure are are we
looking at um and if there was a policy
that would guide ourselves just as much
as it would guide the working group um
and and it would be something to report
against that's that's that's where I'm
I'm coming from I just come back well
the target is to bring the B budget into
balance if if the budget's in balance or
generating the Surplus then you don't
have a buffer on the outside so the
target is the funding budget Gap the
900,000 currently um some of that might
be found quite easily some things will
move uh from one way to another but
that's your T that's the council's
target not the amount it just holds um
aside you you are but you are you are
looking on a on a annualized basis Steve
I mean I I'm looking at the the midterm
Financial strategy I'm looking at the
the the fiveyear period Sur which is the
line that that's been reported um that
that's sorry chair that that's what I'm
looking at is the the figures in the
table in the report the the long-term
position indicates the highest current
level of deficit is 969 th000 so that's
the target over the long term and Target
on recurring savings not just cash ups
and
downs
Council yeah I'm starting to think maybe
we don't really need a policy but we
actually need some kind of uh more
easily recognizable metrics like um
councelor craigy suggested about how
long you could run just on reserves like
if you had to just rely on core Services
how long could you run on reserve and
then that would give you know something
along those lines and then you wouldn't
necessarily have a policy binding you
down but it would give you a good
indicator like oh this one's you know
going red maybe we should do something
about that you know it's just an example
I don't know probably better um metrics
to be using than that
but
just to sort of add add finally to that
the the fact that you know the debate
and sort of building a policy is
actually sometimes useful in itself
because it gives you gives all the
counselors a deeper understanding of
exactly how things work and while
counselors often have lots of time to
look at all the detail we also need to
be conscious of uh the general public
who also need to generally understand
have a bit of an overview of of what the
situation is and haven't necessarily got
the time or the education in financial
matters to be able to to deeply dig into
into all the details so it's always nice
to have a a polic that simplifies it as
far as possible and that discussion
around what the policy is can be helpful
in
itself okay thank you let's uh we're
going to wrap this before we move on on
to to Peter's presentation
um I propose that we do this in two
chunks one is that I make a proposal
that you can vote on um and then after
that has been voted on then we vote on
block uh to the recommendations which
are in the thing can we do that chair so
you've got your proposal as an amendment
which uh has been seconded so you should
take that uh as Amendment first okay and
the proposal is this Council should
adopt a reserves
policy um that is proposed by me from
the chair has been seconded um by
councelor craigy could I have a show of
hands of those in favor of that
Amendment
please and those
against looks like a
split casting
vote with my casting vote um which will
be
four
um and therefore we will
um take that forward as a recommendation
to for
Council um move moving now to the main
block of recommendations uh at the end
of the um section 151 officers report um
that this committee recommends to full
Council that the Tores U band council
tax for this um this year be increased
by
2.99% that
the net revenue budget um is
12194 million as um outlined in the
report um that the contributions to the
council's reserves um outlined
in hang
on I'm probably giving you things that
actually aren't let me do it off the end
of
the is that correct it should be it
should be the same should be the same
and uh the contribution to council's
reserves outlined in paragraph 114 are
approved and that in light of the risks
the council's finances identified within
the report that the member working group
continue its work to bring the council's
budgets back into balance um could I
have a I I uh a proposal on that Council
Hudson and a second to that please
councelor inch um all those in favor
please
show and that is
unanimous okay thank you very much um
moving now to the capital
program uh and uh for that we turn to
the deputy uh section 15 one officer
Peter uh thank you chair good evening
counselors going to give a update on the
capital program for
2425 um so the capital program covers
the next five years it consists of
approved projects um referred to as pids
these are all funded by reserves
contributions from revenue Capital
receipts and grants so at the bottom on
the slide there we've got the capital
program brought forward that was
approved from Full Council uh last
February in 2023 where we had
26.9
million pound program with 29.1 million
pound of funding with A2 million pound
Surplus slide
please so to this um we have a couple of
new new projects to uh update the
program with this year uh the first one
there is one new project um to be added
which is um replacement wise Thin Client
PCS so these are all the desktop um PCS
that all the council staff use um this
PID is for £70,000 so so it's not big in
the context of the program but it's used
for our desktop strategy which is going
um going forward so it's all the it
infrastructure um so sort of a vital
part of that um second on there we've
got Community Land trusts uh revolving
Loan Fund so back in 2019 um for Council
authorized £600,000 of borrowing to fund
a revolving Loan Fund so the key points
of this
are this is for loans for affordable
housing um for Community funds so all
the loans would have to be approved
through CNR uh the loans are from a
range from 75 to
150,000 they'd be secured with a legal
charge against property and we'd charge
them an interest comparable to what we'd
get charged so that's from the pwb which
is the Public Works loan board and these
are really intended as shortterm lending
sort for five years or less just to get
these sort projects over the finish
line so those are the two two additions
we're proposing um during the year
however there's also been significant
changes can I just interrupt minute is
it like to ask a question do you want
questions during or at the end um feel
free what would you I was just wondering
why is it going in now when it was
agreed in
2019 uh yeah so it was agreed in 2019 we
haven't actually had any um we haven't
had any applications since due to it
being due to the loans being for Capital
purposes it needs to be formally put
into the capital program and it never
was at the time so is it just and like
to remind people that it's there uh a
little bit to remind people there but
also um we're required to have all
capital program all capital projects
need to be also approved by full Council
not just the whereas we approve the
borrowing through the treasury policy um
we also need to approve the capital um
because it's a capital loan it's sort of
a a technical sort of accounting okay
thank you thing but yeah so it's just
updating that thank
you yeah so those are the two additions
we propo proposing um however during the
year the program has been updated um
quite significantly already um we've had
20.7 million pounds worth of uh capital
projects added during the year this is
largely down to the appor clean Maritime
Innovation Center now this takes the
total Capital tool program up to 47.2
million and with adjusted funding of 50
million so this gives us a surplus of a
of3 million pounds on the capital
program however um there's a little
caveat to that which is um the bottom
half half that slide there which is the
vehicle program so with our refuge
fleets we fund them over over the long
over the long term so we're funding the
vehicle program out to 3233 which is
when sort of the second big refresh of
all the recycling Vehicles is due and
what that means is we're sort of saving
up each year to to pay for that in the
end so as we're looking at a program for
five years what that means is we've got
some savings at the end of that five
years for those vehicles so what I'm
spending a long way to say there is um
that3 million pound Surplus actually 2
million of it relates to the vehicle
program which is just us sort of saving
up to buy those Vehicles so we've really
got a real Surplus on the program of
about a million which in the context of
uh 47 or 42 47 million is you know isn't
isn't isn't massive as you'll see on the
next
slide so that 42 million based on the
general program um um also is under some
future pressures so we've listed a few
few of the pressures we're under or the
main pressures we're under there so this
is the Leisure centers um are all going
reasonably well towards the end end of
life we have transition to Net Zero and
we've got no new pids in the in the
program from 24 to 29 so that's anything
which might come up in the next five
years really uh the linear defense um
there's a big project which is they're
working on with the environment agency
which where we're unsure of um what will
be required from the council as future
inflation and the maritime Innovation
Center also has some pressures on the on
the funding on the funding Envelope as
it's being
developed
um now just just before we go to the
recommendations is also probably the
perfect time to mention also torage was
identified as one of 20 councils to form
a leveling up partnership with
government uh where there's 400 million
pound worth of funding spread over those
20 councils um now that's sort of good
news for for torage um majority of that
funding will be capital in nature um
don't have too many details at this
point but it's likely to be signed off
on a project by project basis so the pro
so the capital program is likely to need
updating it during next year um and this
funding is likely to also have quite a
short time
um so that's it really I'll just move on
to the recommendations there which is um
that members recommend to full Council
that the capital program is updated to
include the PID for the wise thin
clients and the to add the Community
Land Trust revolving Loan
Fund thank you I'm happy to take any
questions Peter thank you for that um
anybody got questions for Peter on that
or
comment councelor Bri thank you chair um
at the beginning of the report you said
that um it also involves so Revenue as
part of the in investment into the
capital projects do you know how much
that
is
um off off off hand we um we fund so we
put in various different amounts from
the budget that Gordon's just gone
through each year um to fund different
projects so off hand I think it's about
800,000 a year goes into the vehicle
program for The Refuge lorries um we
also put in I think it's 80,000 a year
for car
Parks um and 880,000 TP a year for it we
also have another 100 for General sort
of property I think that's that's the
majority of the the
funds councelor cot Anin thank you um
it's in relation to the Apple door clean
maritime Innovation Center um it says
that there's grants of 18 and a half
million um what say we were told before
that it was 15.6 million from central
government so I was wondering what makes
up the extra nearly three million yeah
so there was there's you're right in the
fact was was
15.6 I think it was um from central
government um it's based on the
funding um cash flow that we've given to
the leveling up fund which is that
actually the forecasted cost of the
project there's about 3 million
difference um so for the capital program
put it in at the full projected cost
although that cost might come down to so
some of that is either additional grant
funding we haven't yet identified um but
also might be delivered with some cost
savings on the project as it's still in
sort of early tender fa
phases councilor
craigy I was just going to ask about the
capital program with the the obviously
you've got the grants and the capital
receipts are these uh figures certain
figures are they established that those
are going to be the grants and the sales
or are they just projections at this
point um there's there's quite a lot of
projections in there to to be honest so
some of its receipts um from pars of
land from that the property property
team will be forecasting but the market
will tell it and but there's there's
quite a lot of forecasted in the future
um built into it because it's over the
over the five years or so um and even
you know things like the grants so we
haven't actually received a lot of so I
think out of the 40 something million we
probably have 10 to 12 so so to speak in
the in in the bank so to speak um but
the rest would be either Revenue
contributions over the next five years
um Capital receipts from sales of um
pass a few few Properties or we also
still have some right to buy properties
from when we had Council housing but
that goes in every year um and there's
also a little bit of borrowing built
into some of the projects as
well councilor kotanen again sorry
that's right I was just wondering um
what the 2.1 million for holw the agre
business relates
to um that's a some well now I think
it's the second phase of the agre
business which is going back while so
it's been in the program for quite a
long time um it was stri it was sort
reassessed to be sort of self- financing
um so it really needs to be looked at
forward but it's the sort project would
probably be looked at by something like
the leveling up fund
with anything else on that um that being
the case that
um
um have you got the recommendation back
up there again there we are back on the
screen um and can I if everybody's happy
can we have a a proposal on on this
recommendation Council Hudson and can I
ask another
question come on in quickly it's about
um the play area program so it's got
90,000 to cover four years and I'm just
concerned whether that's enough and what
it has been previously has that gone
down
significantly um it doesn't sound like
very much money to cover four
years um my understanding is that's that
that was a five-year program which um I
think finished um which was due to
finish in 23 24 so the 90,000 is sort of
what's left over in it um so it hasn't
been reallocated to
anything there is obviously a lot of
pressure on our play areas that was the
money at the time that was set aside to
underpin the play strategy was it not so
the thought it needs
replenishing to make sure that our
player player is stay up to
standard ex um chair that that that that
may or may not be the the case um we're
considering tday night that's the the
actual program that's previously been
approved all we're considering tonight
is any additions that have gone through
the the project process which are those
two on there so in you're considering
the
recommendations that CNR have made
you're scrutinizing those
recommendations um you can't start
considering adding or taking other
things out because we don't know uh what
the impact of that might be um um and if
there's a suggestion that that's that's
not enough that's for a different
course then perhaps the lead member for
leisure needs to um um look at um that's
not me anymore it's not you anymore I
know um I will raise it lead member for
leisure sorry I will raise it with the
lead
members councelor Piper sort of um may
need to instigate a new pit um given
the um to fight against everything else
um so we have a proposer um do I have a
second please for for this um councelor
Elliot uh all those in favor of the
recommendation as on the screen please
um or as we've seen on the screen and
that is uh unanimous uh thank you very
much um moving to the the forward
plan
um you will see that
um as well for the next meeting in March
cycle 7 as well as the qbr uh which is
quarter three um the uh we are also
looking at the review of the qbr pro
process
um and
um we have worked up a
question um which
um councelor craigy ccor denate um and
others have have worked on together with
John uh Waters and it has then survive
contact with um uh the members of the
senior management team uh who I waved it
at to see if they had comment and there
was some constructive input from there
as well um and the um um questionnaire
will go out to all
counselors and this time also all
members of the senior management team
and all members of the operational
management team and the aim of the
questionnaire is to try to gauge the
usefulness uh to individual counselors
and Senior officers um and to seek
recommendations as to where it could be
fine-tuned further um for those who
weren't involved before the current qbr
format that we use is just over two
years old um having been redesigned by
this committee uh and um
so it is timely to um do uh ask for a
bit of feedback to see how people use it
um by inviting all counselors um to
comment on it uh it might um encourage
some counselors to um take a greater
interest in it and uh after this meeting
I will um send an email out to all
counselors uh asking them please to try
to ensure that they do complete the
survey when Democratic Services send it
out uh so by that we will have the
uh the feedback from that questionnaire
in time for the next meeting uh which is
why I mentioned that that's where the
material will come from hopefully that
we will see or not
um um we also have um a um slot on
Recruitment and Retention um there and
then cycle eight is very much um est3
strategy and then doing a review on
Grounds Maintenance which again is two
years since um the contract was taken in
Hand by the council and it's therefore
it's right that we look at it um after
two years and um we're also getting
update um on planning enforcement um uh
workload and capacity um which is came
from our last presentation and meeting
everybody happy with
that good Mr denate can I just ask not
on the cycle that happy with that it's
just the keep under review box um that
we have and it it's probably just the
way it's being managed with this kind of
group from how it used to be previously
but tended to be keep under the review
tended to stay on because it meant that
we kept it under review and it was there
to remind us and it's just that on the
September keep under review we had the
discretionary versus statutary spend um
which was
a it was alligated against member budget
working group but I mean that does seem
to be an area that we probably do need
to keep an eye on or under review I just
wonder how we're going to do that if
it's not on here and and how it came off
because I don't remember us discussing
it after September so I'm not sure why
it's not still there
um it's on the September forward plan
but I mean to be fair had spotted
it okay um we I will review that
together with officers and we'll just
look back and
see what's fallen off it and what
and if if it's not if we haven't taken a
deliberate decision to take it off we
can put it back there if sometimes
perhaps it's it's better to have more
things in that list if only to jog our
memory and fine then we it means that
things don't get completely lost um
there were eight in September and
there's five now and it has moved around
a bit in the previous months and I'm not
quite sure okay um well I don't propose
reviewing it now but we will we will
look at that and and um uh be in a
position to report next meeting
um
um that um brings to uh a close
um tonight's meeting thank you very much
and just to
confirm the
um next meeting is a um morning meeting
um on Tuesday the 19th of March at
10:00 um here in bitterford town hall um
otherwise uh with nothing more Ado I
close this meeting and thank you very
much for your
attendance thank
you